- [Flight Attendant] Please
remember wearing your mask
or covering over both your nose and mouth
is required throughout our flight.
(light upbeat music)
- My name is Sebastian Modak,
and I'm one of many travel
writers no longer traveling.
Like many, the thought of
flying now makes me nervous.
But as a formerly frequent
flyer, I'm also curious.
Many months into the COVID-19 pandemic,
I wondered what does the
new normal of air travel
look like around the world?
How are different airlines,
different airports,
and different countries
responding to the pandemic?
To find out, I had to get on a flight.
And, stuck as I am in the United States
for the foreseeable future,
I also needed to call
on some others for help.
- I can't believe how many shops are open.
- I'm feeling pretty
good about the flight.
- [Sebastian] I decided
to take a quick trip
from New York where I
live to Chicago and back.
Eva Xaio was set to fly to
Istanbul on a reporting trip.
And George Downs was making
the trip home to London
after a work visit to Toulouse.
First, I wanted to get an idea
from someone who knows
what they're talking about
of what I should and
shouldn't do on a plane.
So I spoke to Dr. Celine Gounder,
infectious disease
specialist and epidemiologist
at NYU and Bellevue Hospital.
- The risk on planes is really related
to the people who are
closest to you on the plane.
The HVAC systems on
planes are quite robust.
And so the air exchanges you get on planes
are actually quite good.
So it's the people sitting
within a couple rows of you
that we really worry about.
And masks and potentially
some sort of eye covering,
face shields, would be really important
for reducing that risk.
- Then I was ready to fly.
By car, by coach, by
train, George, Eva and I
made our way to our respective airports.
And we were all struck by one thing.
I've never seen it this empty.
- It does feel quiet in here.
- [Eva] This station's
usually not in this empty.
- I had decided to fly two
different domestic airlines
to get an idea of what sets them apart.
American Airlines to Chicago,
Delta Airlines back to New York.
- [Pilot] Hey, good afternoon,
ladies and gentlemen.
- And even when I bought the tickets,
I knew there was gonna be a difference.
When I look at the seat
maps on American Airlines,
everything's up for grabs,
including the middle seat.
On Delta, however, they've
blocked out the middle seat,
or at least it appears that way.
In George's case, his
entire route was unusual,
a result of a drop in flight frequency
based on diminishing demand.
- I have to go to Charles
de Gaulle in Paris
and then swap planes and
go to London from there.
- [Sebastian] For Eva, things
were mostly normal at home.
The situation in Turkey
was more uncertain.
- Turkey's had over 1,000,
1,500 cases every day.
Whereas, Hong Kong I
think had seven today.
- Because of our different routes,
we had different arrival
regulations we had to follow.
In my case, the arrival
protocols in Chicago and New York
more closely resembled
recommendations than rules.
It's kind of interesting
that I'm seeing the sign
telling me to quarantine
as I'm leaving (laughing),
because I did not see it
as I arrived in Chicago.
Meanwhile, George was ready
for two weeks of quarantine at home.
- When I travel from England to France,
that's a travel corridor.
So I was able to arrive here
and get about my day without
having to quarantine.
However, the same, unfortunately for me,
doesn't work in the other direction.
So when I get back,
I'm going to have to
quarantine for two weeks.
- [Sebastian] But even then,
when he arrived in London,
he found that rules and processes
had seemed to relax a bit.
- When I walked through,
nobody took my temperature.
- [Sebastian] Eva, meanwhile,
got tested before leaving
with a self testing kit she
acquired from her doctor.
Upon arriving in Turkey,
she would have to present
a health declaration form,
but there was no quarantine requirement.
She would have to
quarantine at home though
when she returned to Hong Kong.
Perhaps the biggest change in flying
everywhere around the world,
regardless of airline or destination,
is the requirement to wear a mask.
It was a mixed bag though
when it came to compliance.
- Mask standards are slipping.
- Everyone's wearing masks, of course.
- People are just coughing
without their masks on
and things like that,
so I'm a little nervous.
And in George's case, there
were rules he had to follow
about the type of mask he was to wear.
- I'm just boarding the plane now,
but there were signs everywhere
saying that I had to have
a disposable surgical mask
specifically for this flight.
- [Sebastian] That's despite
Dr. Gounder telling me
that cloth, surgical, or
KN95 would all do the trick.
- Any of those that you
showed us would be fine.
- [Sebastian] Eva brought back up
because of the length
of her 12 hour flight.
- I've been told I should just wear it
for a maximum of six hours.
So actually I have another one.
I have to switch in the middle.
- [Sebastian] Before flying,
I had heard from some people
that the boarding process had changed
from the cryptic zone system
to a far more logical
and far more COVID safe
back to front process.
It turns out that was only
the case with some airlines.
Eva who was flying Turkish
Airlines had that experience.
- It looks like they're boarding
from the back to the front.
- And I only had that
experience on my way back,
when flying Delta.
On American Airlines, by contrast,
not only were middle seats not blocked out
and the plane packed,
but the boarding process
was business as usual.
Delta said it will be
blocking off middle seats
at least through January 6, 2021.
American confirmed it is
not blocking middle seats,
nor has it changed its boarding process.
The airline did say it informs customers
when a flight is full
and allows them to change
to a more open flight without fees.
George's flights were full.
And not only were middle
seats not blocked off,
but he found himself in one.
In my case, it was one of many parts
of the process I found surprising,
mainly how different the experience was
between Delta and American,
two of the United States'
big three airlines.
As a passenger, I've always thought
there has been very little
light between the two.
Through their responses to the
pandemic, that has changed.
On my first flight to Chicago,
besides the face masks,
not a lot had changed.
This flight back to New York
was a whole other story.
There was constant reminders
that this was not normal.
The middle seats were blocked.
Nobody was sitting next to anyone else.
Amenities were altered across the board
no matter what plane we were on on.
On American, I received
nothing but a single wet wipe.
Flight attendants only
appeared to collect garbage.
On Delta, I got the wipe
plus a Ziploc bag of snacks and water.
Eva got a full boxed cold meal.
Her hygiene kit was quite
a bit more impressive
than the single wipes both
George and I were treated to.
When I arrived back in New York,
at a kiosk near a baggage claim,
I was asked to fill out paperwork
with my personal information.
In it, I agreed to quarantine for 14 days.
A week after my flight,
I hadn't been contacted by
anyone to check that I was.
So what is flying like in 2020?
The short answer is it depends.
Safeguards vary widely
from country to country,
and even within one country.
Most people are still choosing
to postpone their trips.
In the week we traveled in
mid-October, for example,
the number of scheduled
flights was down 47%
compared to last year.
In the United States during that week,
the number of travelers
going through TSA checkpoints
surpassed 1 million for
the first time since March,
but that's still less than
half as many as last year.
No transit authority, airport, or airline
has figured out a standard
one size fits all model
to being 100% safe in
these unprecedented times.
Passenger numbers reflect the uncertainty
many feel around air travel right now.
(light upbeat music)